>> WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG
SUNDAY SHOW.
EVEN P THOUGH PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAYS HE HASN'T DECIDED IF HE
WILL RUN FOR REELECTION IN 2024,
VOTERS SAY THEY DON'T WANT HIM.
IN A NEW "ABC NEWS/WASHINGTON
POST POLL," MORE THAN HALF OF
AMERICANS WANT SOMEONE ELSE TO
BE THE PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE.
AND DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES ARE
GETTING THE MESSAGE, DISTANCING
THEMSELVES FROM THE PRESIDENT
AND EVEN ATTACKING HIM.
HERE'S O'ROURKE WHO OBVIOUSLY
SAID THIS FOR POLITICAL REASONS.
>> CANDIDATE BIDEN DIDN'T SPEND
A DIME OR A DAY IN THE RIO
GRANDE VALLEY OR REALLY ANYWHERE
IN TEXAS FOR THAT MATTER, ONCE
WE GOT DOWN THE HOMESTRETCH OF
THE GENERAL ELECTION.
YOU GOT TO BE LOCKING EYEBALLS
WITH THE PEOPLE THAT YOU WANT TO
FIGHT FOR AND SERVE AND HIS
VOTES YOU WANT TO WIN.
>> PRETTY ROUGH STUFF ON JOE
BIDEN THERE, ALICIA.
IT'S FUNNY TO HEAR THIS FROM
BETO O'ROURKE BECAUSE I RECALL
NOT TOO LONG AGO, SAY, DURING
THE 2020 CAMPAIGN, WHEN BETO
O'ROURKE ALONG WITH ALL THESE
DEMOCRATS SORT OF JOINED HANDS
AND ALL KISSED THE FEET OF JOE
BIDEN, LET'S TAKE A LOOK BACK
DOWN MEMORY LANE.
>> TOMORROW MARCH 3RD, 2020, I
WILL BE CASTING MY BALLOT FOR
JOE BIDEN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> WE NEED SOMEBODY WHO CAN
RE-ESTABLISH THE MORAL AUTHORITY
OF THE UNITED STATES.
WE NEED SOMEBODY WHO WILL FIGHT
FOR DEMOCRACY HERE AND ABROAD
BECAUSE DEMOCRACY IS UNDER
ATTACK HERE AND ABROAD.
WE NEED JOE BIDEN.
>> MAN, HE DIDN'T SEEM TO HAVE A
PROBLEM BACK THEN, ALICIA.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS
EARLIER.
REMEMBER THAT DAY WHEN HE -- IT
BECAME EVIDENT THAT IT WAS GOING
TO BE JOE BIDEN AND ALL THE
CANDIDATES ONE BY ONE JUST
STARTED DROPPING AND THROWING IN
THEIR SUPPORT, MAN, HOW THINGS
HAVE CHANGED; RIGHT?
>> WOW.
>> WE'RE ALSO SEEING SO MANY OF
THE CANDIDATES OUT THERE RIGHT
NOW IN THESE SWING STATES WHO
ARE ALSO REALLY STRUGGLING WHEN
THEY ARE ASKED DO YOU WANT THE
PRESIDENT TO COME OUT AND
CAMPAIGN FOR YOU?
LIKE MARK KELLY, THE SENATOR OUT
OF ARIZONA, WHO'S FIGHTING FOR
HIS SEAT, BACK IN AUGUST, HE WAS
ASKED WOULD YOU WANT THE
PRESIDENT TO COME CAMPAIGN FOR
YOU?
AND HIS ANSWER WAS IF SOMEONE
WANTS TO COME TO ARIZONA AND
TALK ABOUT ARIZONA ISSUES, I'LL
BE THERE.
IF SOMEONE -- HE'S TALKING ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
WE HAD A SIMILAR SITUATION WITH
SENATOR BENNETT OUT OF COLORADO,
WE ASKED HIM, DO YOU WANT HIM TO
COME OUT HERE AND CAMPAIGN FOR
YOU?
SIMILAR TYPE OF DANCE AROUND
WITHOUT SAYING YES OR NO.
>> THAT'S GOT TO BE A PRETTY
HARD PILL TO SWALLOW, IF YOU'RE
JOE BIDEN.
BUT I THINK IT'S OBVIOUS, GUY,
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
LISTEN TO EVEN THE FORMER WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY JEN PSAKI,
WHAT SHE SAYS.
>> LOOK, I THINK THAT DEMOCRATS,
IF THE ELECTION IS ABOUT WHO IS
THE MOST EXTREME, AS WE SAW, YOU
KNOW, KEVIN MCCARTHY TOUCH ON
THERE WITH MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE, I WILL SAY HER NAME
SITTING ON HIS LEFT SIDE, THEN
THEY ARE GOING TO WIN.
IF IT IS A REFERENDUM ON THE
PRESIDENT, THEY WILL LOSE, AND
THEY KNOW THAT.
>> I MEAN, GUY, THEY KNOW THAT
JOE BIDEN IS BASICALLY THE
ANCHOR AROUND THE NECK OF THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY
>> THAT'S HIS FORMER CHIEF
SPOKESWOMAN SAYING THAT.
RIGHT?
BY THE THE WAY, YOU MENTIONED
THE MARK KELLY SOUND BITE OUT IN
ARIZONA.
MORE RECENTLY HE WAS ASKED
ANOTHER REALLY TOUGH QUESTION BY
A NEWS REPORTER OUT THERE, DO
YOU THINK JOE BIDEN'S DOING A
GOOD JOB?
AND MARK KELLY SAT THERE FOR
LIKE 10 SECONDS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT TO SAY ABOUT THAT.
IT IS NOT A REAL STUMPER, AT
LEAST IT SHOULDN'T BE.
HAVE SOMETHING READY.
ON THAT SOUND BITE THAT WE JUST
HEARD FROM PSAKI, I THINK THAT
SHE PROBABLY KNOWS DEEP DOWN
THAT SHE'S DREAMING IF SHE FEELS
LIKE THIS MIGHT BE EITHER A
REFERENDUM ON THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, IN WHICH CASE
THEY LOSE, OR A REFERENDUM ON
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE WHO MOST
AMERICANS HAVE NEVER HEARD OF?
SHE'S NOT MY CUP OF TEA.
I'M VERY OPEN ABOUT THAT.
BUT THEY SAY MARJORIE WHAT
VERSUS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES?
I THINK THAT THIS IS VERY
WISHFUL THINKING.
SHE MADE THIS LIKE IT IS EITHER
GOING TO BE THIS OR THAT.
THE SECOND CHOICE WAS A
REFERENDUM ON THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
IT IS THE JOB OF THE REPUBLICANS
TO MAKE IT SO.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MIDTERMS.
THE BIG ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM IS
ALWAYS WHETHER OR NOT JOE BIDEN
IS ACTUALLY GOING TO RUN AGAIN
IN 2024.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE HAVE DECIDED
HE'S NOT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING TO
HAPPEN?
>> LISTEN, POLITICIANS ARE --
THEY'RE LITTLE PIRANHAS WAITING
TO TAKE A BITE.
IT IS EASY TO GET BEHIND JOE
BIDEN.
LOOKING AT THE FACT HE DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE HE'S SPRY OR WITH IT
ALL THE TIME, HE MAY IN FACT
DECIDE NOT TO RUN AGAIN FOR HIS
HEALTH.
I WOULDN'T FAULT HIM FOR THAT.
HE IS OLDER IN YEARS.
NOT ALL 70, 80-YEAR-OLDS ARE ALL
THE SAME.
I WON'T ATTACK BIDEN FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE.
BETO O'ROURKE IS THE EXACT KIND
OF WET NOODLE WHO WOULD LOVE TO
TAKE A BITE OUT OF HIM THINKING
THERE MAY BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
ME HERE.
THAT'S WHAT POLITICIANS DO
ESPECIALLY DEMOCRATS RIGHT NOW
WHEN BIDEN DOESN'T HAVE ANY TYPE
OF LEGACY ACHIEVEMENT THAT THEY
CAN ATTACH THEMSELVES TO.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WHY IS
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND
DEMOCRATS TAKING THE TURN
TOWARDS EXTREMIST REPUBLICANS?
BECAUSE THEY UNDERSTAND THAT
WHEN WHAT WE CALL KITCHEN TABLE
ISSUES, ON ISSUES AMERICANS
REALLY CARE ABOUT RIGHT NOW,
REPUBLICANS CERTAINLY HAVE AN
EDGE.
ABBOTT IS UP 7 1/2%, UP FROM 5,
HEADING TOWARDS DOUBLE DIGITS,
GOING BACK TO BETO, IN THE SAME
WEEK HE SENDS A BUNCH OF
MIGRANTS TO THE NORTHEAST AND
SUPPOSEDLY IS VULNERABLE THERE
OR IN THE SAME WEEK THAT ROE
VERSUS WADE BECOMES A BIG ISSUE
IN TEXAS FOR BETO TO TALK ABOUT.
WHEN SOMETHING DOES TURN HIS
WAY, HE IS NOT DOING WELL,
BECAUSE LIKE I REFERENCED IN THE
A BLOCK SO MANY VOTERS ARE
SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M LIBERAL OR DEMOCRAT, BUT I'M
NOT WHAT THIS IS.
I'M NOT A MEMBER OF THE CHURCH
OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
MY IDENTITY, MY GENDER IS NOT
EVERYTHING ABOUT ME.
I NEED SOMETHING ELSE.
IF BIDEN IS LEADING THAT
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO JUMP SHIP TO INCLUDE
THE POLITICIANS DOWN THE LINE.
>> I LOVE SEEING BETO THERE.
I MEAN, THE FIRST THING I
THOUGHT ABOUT WHEN I SAW HIM
SLAMMING JOE BIDEN WAS JUST HOW
QUICK HE WAS -- I MEAN, HE JUST
FLOWS WITH THE WIND AND DOES
WHATEVER HE THINKS IS GOING TO
BENEFIT HIM IN THE MOMENT, AND
IT'S JUST AMAZING TO SEE.
>> ALSO CAN I JUST SAY I MEAN HE
SAID THAT FOR POLITICAL
EXPEDIENCY; CORRECT?
HOWEVER, HE'S NOT WRONG ABOUT
TEXANS BEING IGNORED BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AND REPUBLICAN